well hello to the audience
my name is dr lawrence de koning i'm an
associate professor at the university of
calgary in calgary alberta canada
and i'm also a clinical biochemist with
alberta precision laboratories
in calgary i'm here to talk to you today
about
applications of laboratory data to
improve health care delivery and patient
outcomes
one major interest of mine from a
research and clinical standpoint
is how to use laboratory data to improve
both the quality of the operations of
the lab but also the quality
of to the healthcare experience at
patients
experience at a hospital setting so i'm
going to give you three examples today
of projects that we've worked on here in
calgary
and so the first project has to do with
how we use glucometers
to reduce unnecessary glucose tolerance
testing in
pregnant women the second example is how
we used some simple tests and very
simple data
to help reduce and eliminate a great
bugaboo to
laboratorians at 72-hour fecal fat
testing
and finally how we use simple common
laboratory test results
to help identify patients undergoing
coronary artery
interventions who are at high risk of
death
three projects so this is the first one
so before i get into it i'd like to
introduce our city calgary alberta
canada
we are the largest metropolitan center
in the province of alberta
um in canada we are a city of 1.4
million people
and from a laboratory standpoint the
entire city and surrounding rural areas
is serviced by one laboratory provider
alberta precision laboratories now we
have labs at all of the major
five hospitals characterized by these
little green boxes on the map in the
left throughout the city
we have um uh small laboratories at
about
um uh five um community testing sites
throughout the city
um and we also have um hospital
laboratories
in rural hospitals and nine rural
hospitals outside of the city
which are in the blue boxes on the right
part of the graph
but um probably you know the majority
of the work that we do in terms of
specimen
you know drawing from patients is done
at these patient phlebotomy centers and
there's 19 of them
and they're in red and they're scattered
throughout the city and they're also
in the rural areas these collection
sites
are responsible for taking blood and
patients taking patient specimens
prepping them for testing but then
transporting them to our central
laboratory
marked by a small gray box in the left
map and the number one that's our
central laboratory that does most of our
community testing
so glucose tolerance testing this is a
big part of laboratory testing for any
laboratory system
we do them in calgary and we do several
different types of glucose tolerance
tests
we do a 50 gram glucose tolerance test
it's actually a gestational diabetes
screening test it's part of the two-step
gestational diabetes screening testing
program that we have
um that initial screening test can be
followed with a 75 gram
oral glucose tolerance test for women
who test in the intermediate range
in plasma glucose after they've received
the screening test
and then we also have just a regular old
75 gram
oral glucose tolerance test for
non-pregnant patients
the majority of these tolerance tests
are performed at these 19
patient phlebotomy collection sites that
are scattered throughout the city
and are found in some of our rural areas
too
only a very small amount about 10
percent are done at our five urban
hospital sites and nine
rural hospitals so most of them are done
at these collection sites there's no
testing done at these collection sites
only
specimen collection now further details
on
how we do tolerance testing so at the
phlebotomy collection sites
what happens is the patient arrives
fasted
a fasting venous blood sample is drawn
um
and that fasting venous blood sample is
opened
and tested with a glucose meter now if
the glucose is
too high on the meter and i'll get into
exactly what that means later
the glucose drink's not given to the
patient
um then the whole blood if the if the um
well at that point the whole blood
sample is spun down
and prepared for transport and if the
initial glucose result was adequate then
um
the glucose drink is given and post load
samples are taken from the patient
and then those samples are spun down and
then all the samples are sent to our
central
um testing lab um in the north
northwestern quadrant of the city
and what's being sent is plasma so this
sample is effectively stabilized at that
point
now to get the testing done it takes
about four hours um from dispatch of the
specimen to the result being populated
in the electronic medical record
now at our urban and rural hospitals uh
we don't have um
the exact same process instead specimens
are drawn spun
and plasma testing is done on site so
you get an immediate result
um on the fasting sample and so if the
result is considered to be too high
then the drink is not given and that
that process is done immediately
and then any subsequent testing of the
specimens is also done immediately
so we get an immediate result and the
patient can walk out
and know that the results are are going
into that medical record
so just some review on what we define as
diabetes
so for non-pregnant patients we define
diabetes according to diabetes
association guidelines which are the
same as
american diabetes except that we use si
units so
diabetes is defined as fasting glucose
greater than equal to seven
and a one c of greater than equal to six
point five percent
or a two hour um post load 75 gram low
glucose of
upgraded middle or equal to 11.1 um you
can also diagnose it based on a random
glucose of greater equal 11.1
but any positive of any of these results
should be followed up with confirmation
by another test if the patient is
asymptomatic
well for pregnant women when we're
trying to diagnose gestational diabetes
we use the two-step um procedure
that starts with a 50 gram load in the
center
box 50 gram glucose load with one hour
post glucose testing
and depending on their glucose result
after that they can be
negative on the far left swim lane they
could be positive on the far right or
they can be intermediate between 7.8 and
11.
if that happens then they are referred
for a 75 gram glucose tolerance test
where we test post low glucose at one
hour
and two hours but before all of that we
actually do a fasting glucose
and if a fasting glucose or a one hour
post low glucose or a two hour post low
glucose any of them
if they are elevated then gestational
diabetes is diagnosed so i want to draw
your attention
to the fasting glucose greater than or
equal to 5.3
so even before any postflow glucose
testing can be done
we can diagnose gestational diabetes in
these patients
so back to the drink why we
why should the drink not be given well
i've alluded to that
um but first of all um you know it's
actually quite inconvenient for the
patient to have to
consume the drink and then wait around
for two hours on subsequent blood draws
to figure out if they have gestational
diabetes or not
or or just regular diabetes if they're
non-pregnant there's also a certain
amount of discomfort and risk associated
with tolerance testing
there's blood collection that's involved
in pregnant women particularly they're
susceptible to vomiting and nausea
these are the major causes for
cancelling these tests
and there is a small risk of
hyperglycemia or or
post load hypoglycemia due to
overactive beta cells and and a
hyperinsulinemic response
and there's some costs associated with
the lab as well which we're very
cognizant of
being part of a public health care
system in canada there's costs and
consumables there's cost to do the
testing
and there's actual staff being involved
in the testing which prevents
other patients from being seen too
um and the patient occupies a chair at
the collection site which could be
taken by another patient um so uh
what is considered to be too high on
that glucose meter at those
collection sites well for the
non-pregnant tolerant tests
we basically have a cutoff of 7.9
millimoles per liter or greater
um and you know if that is exceeded then
we don't get the drink
and we came up with that because it's
7.0 plus
0.8 and the 0.8 is the
whole blood meter versus plasma core lab
bias that we see
and the 7.0 is the threshold for
diabetes but for the pregnant tolerance
tests
we don't we at the point of this project
didn't have a cut off for
not for denying the drink so our
objective was to define a meter cup
point with
adequate sensitivity and specificity for
gestational diabetes by fasting plasma
alone
and the fasting plasma result alone
would be greater than equal to 5.3
millivolts per liter
so we can make a call of whether patient
has gestational diabetes
right away if we can implement that cut
point
so our methods were first of all to
obtain all of our whole blood fasting
glucose media results
we link it to the plasma fasting glucose
result from the same
tube of blood remember we're testing
them on both the meteor and the lab
and then perform rock curve analysis to
identify a
fasting whole blood meter cut point that
has high sensitivity and specificity
for that fasting plasma glucose of
greater than equal to 5.3
you know the meter cannot be used to
diagnose gestational diabetes
but we can if we set a threshold high
enough
we can probably predict whether
someone's going to go on and get a
plasma result of 5.3 or greater
so this is just a bland altman plot
showing the relationship between
the core laboratory plots and glucose on
the bottom and
the difference between the two on on the
on the y
axis and all it's showing is that you
know our glucose meters are
overestimating um
uh plasma glucose on the low end of the
lab result
so i'm not going to show you the gory
details of the rock curve analysis but
at the bottom highlighted in yellow
is the cut point of 5.2 which is
actually greater than or equal to 5.3
and that cut point on the meter has a
sensitivity of 91.4
and specificity of 91 for
a plasma glucose of greater than equal
to 5.3
and so over a two year period we
end up identifying um 323
women who actually have a plasma glucose
over
over or or equal to 5.3 using that meter
cut point so that's great
so those women can be they don't have to
have the drink at all so that's an
improvement
in their experience going to the
collection site
but there's 370 individuals who are
denied the drink inappropriately and
those women are going to have to come
back for retesting because that cut
point
uh is not the best uh based upon the
number of women that we test
um and so there's another cut point that
we looked at too and that's 6.0
so it only has a sensitivity to 25 but a
specificity of 99.9
and that one we called
88 individuals over two years
if we if we use that cut point who would
be appropriately denied the glucose
drink
and over that period of time there are
only three individuals
who we inappropriately denied it to if
we would have implemented it
so this was you know all this data is
showing what we would get
if we implemented these cut points is
based on our existing data so we looked
at this data and thought to ourselves
what should we
put into place here and so we had to
talk to the endocrinologist to discuss
with them
what would be best and we all agreed
that using a cut point of greater than
equal to
6.1 or greater than equal to 6 was
better
because there were only three false
denials of the drink per year
and you know basically individuals that
had a you know an error
in this process meaning they would be
denied the drink inappropriately
they would get a automatic callback
through a laboratory information system
rule that we built
so they could come in and get an
appointment so uh for retesting so that
was a nice outcome of of
implementing this this cut point
um and so we actually did implement that
6.0 cut point we also implemented the
cut point
of greater than equal to 5.3 on all of
our hospital labs for that fasting
sample that's done on site
we didn't have to worry about you know a
rc curve analysis because we are testing
plasma glucose
and so we say okay if the fasting result
is 5.3 or more then it's a diagnosis and
we don't need to do any
further testing so the patient can go
home
so this was a very nice um result at the
end of the day so
by these two changes we save about 145
women per year
from having to get the glucose drink so
this is a great um a great
outcome and it saves the lab about 10
000 a year
so this has been published in the may
2019 edition of the journal of applied
laboratory medicine so you can
read more about it there now
the second quality improvement study
using data
i'd like to show you is a project we
embarked on regarding
72-hour fecal fat testing so this test
is a very old test
it came to be you know four years after
the end of the second world war um
it's a it's a manual test using large
quantities of acids bases
and uh and solvents and
it requires a patient to go sort of on a
fat treadmill they consume a high fat
diet for a total of five days in the
last three
days of that diet they collect their
stool in a paint can
and the whole purpose of this test is to
identify fat male absorption and male
digestion
in children you know the high fat diet
is
is is recommended but not expected and
so
dietary intake is measured with a
dietary assessment tool and fat intake
is calculated based upon that
and compared to the fat output that we
measure in the 72-hour collection
so this is what it looks like so you
start with a stool specimen in a paint
can and then you dilute it in water
and then you add rocks to the can and
shake it up in a paint shaker
to make a slurry and then you extract
the stool fats which are mostly in
triglyceride format
at that stage in ethanol and you add to
it a very strong base and warm it and
that creates soaps
it turns the um breaks down the
triglycerides into
into fatty acids and glycerol and then
converts the triglycerides into fatty
acid soaps
and fatty acids into fatty acid soaps
and glycerol
then um you add hydrochloric acid to
convert the soaps back into fatty acids
you protonate them
you do it on ice because it's an
exothermic reaction and then you extract
those fatty acids with petroleum
ether while shaking vigorously
and then you evaporate the petroleum
ether in a hot water bath leaving fatty
acid crystals behind
which you solubilize in ethanol
then you add to it a ph indicator and
titrate it with a strong base
until you get a nice blue color and the
amount of base that you titrate in
millimoles
is proportional to the moles of fatty
acids present in that aliquot
which then you can use to back calculate
the total amount of fatty acid
in the original 72 hour stool specimen
and then you can express that result
in millimoles excreted per day now
we have two or we did have two reference
intervals for this test
for patients under 7 years of age what
was considered to be normal was
less than 7 millimoles per day output
but for patients greater than equal to 7
years of age it was less than 21
moles per day output we had a separate
reference interval
um when comparing fat intake versus fat
output as a percent
these are for those children that are
assessed by a dietary assessment tool a
diet diary
and that was zero to 9.9 but most of our
testing
um our reporting was the millimoles per
day
so some interesting information
historically on the metrics
uh performance on this test um so our
turnaround time for this test was two
weeks
from acetic specimentary reporting
result um and we eventually moved to one
month turnaround time when we made some
changes to it
and it was a very labor-intensive test
as i've mentioned
but it took one staff member an entire
shift to report out nine results which
is really low output
um the test had 20 variation in the
results of month to month
in our quality control pools and our run
to run variation was 10
in specimens that we would run and carry
over from from
the previous run to the current run so
the maximum total and precision of this
test was 22
not very good when you compare it to
automated chemistry analysis
uh other other interesting things about
this test is we were not evaluated by
any
agency for our performance relative to
our peers just because one did not exist
there was no proficiency tests in the
scheme um
so impacts of this test while it's
difficult for patients to
collect their stool for three days but
also difficult to go into a high fat
diet for five days
they also write down their diet on a
piece of paper regardless of whether a
child or an adult and for the adults
that
information was not used for the kids
the diet has to be recorded by the
family for those days
and stool collection in a for a child is
rather difficult
um you know i suppose it's easier if
they're in diapers but it's still
not easy and it's hard for staff there's
significant bio safety controls chemical
hygiene controls
it's a manual procedure and then if we
are doing
intake versus output input versus output
in children we have to have a dietitian
involved to make sure that the total fat
intake is calculated properly from the
diet data
lots of problems in terms of
interpretation so we'd often get
incomplete um collections um any
patients um who
actually were experiencing steatorrhea
um their response to that would be
reduce their fat
intake to make their life a little bit
more pleasant diarrhea itself
less unless is a lesser known fact
actually increases fat output no matter
the actual pathology that causes it
and then the final step the titration
step
the variation associated with that
measure was actually
surprisingly large and most of this
information was summarized in an audit
that was done in the late 90s and
published in early 2000 and the
bottom line from that audit um that
british audit was that
this test makes it makes it a very
unsatisfactory investigation and the
performance of it
certainly and probably of little
clinical value so
um when we were looking at this um you
know
this test was identified uh as one that
could be
probably not done so this is about 15
years after this came out
so there's lots of alternatives to this
test that's another point of this
article
i'm not going to get into too many of
them here but basically we have other
tests in the lab that can be used that
are simpler
that can help rule in or rule out fat
male absorption and maldigestion
there are some patients that you just
don't want to do this test on you know
they're probably not eating enough to
have
you know sufficient fat intake to begin
with
you know patients with frank pancreatic
insufficiency it's not really
useful to do this test um and then if
you if you're just trying to
diagnose it and the patient has gray and
greasy stool i don't think you need to
do any other testing
and save maybe confirming fat lobules
that are present in the specimen
so our goal was to first of all reduce
the amount of fecal fat testing done in
our lab and hopefully replace the test
because it's a really bad test and not
that helpful for
clinical investigations so what we did
was we first of all
pulled all of our utilization data for
fecal fat um
we looked at ordering patterns to
determine if we can um
you know immediately institute some
restrictions for a quick win
and also we performed some research on
the existing data
in the lab information system to see if
any characteristics of the specimen can
predict abnormality
by the van der camer test and we also
did some testing of bank specimens to
see if that
those results from alternative tests
would help
so first thing we found out was that you
know in these bar graphs um the majority
of the
of the tests that were being run were on
patients who were adults greater than
equal to 18 years of age
and that's inappropriate this test was
really designed to pick up
you know extreme fat malnutrition in
kids so we instituted a
ordering restriction before 2015 and
that reduced
our ordering of this test and our
testing of this test by 80
right off the bat um so that was that
was a very quick win but we still had
some residual ordering
um in kids and adults um and so
um we decided that you know this test
could only be done by permission
by consultation with myself and any
specimens that arrived at the lab
that that were not pre-approved by
myself they would be screened with a
microscopic investigation for fat
globules
um and we found that um you know when
presented with these
paws and egg results the clinicians
admitted that they probably didn't need
to do any further testing
um and sometimes um we would uh well
in a later stage of the intervention we
just started to run
this test reflexively and reporting the
results
and um you know the the physicians never
complained
um and when asked about it they said
well we probably never needed the fecal
fat
camera test originally so this is a good
move
um in terms of the data how we use it we
looked at whether the weight of the
specimen
could predict abnormality by the fecal
fat test itself so this is an roc curve
analysis
of the specimen weight the 72-hour
specimen weight versus positivity
um using the 21 millimole per per day
um cut off uh for patients that are
greater than equal to seven years of age
and the first thing you see um you know
is it's not a bad roc curve
and the c statistic or area under the
curve is 0.74 so that's actually quite
high
for something as simple as the weight of
the specimen
as a predictor of abnormality and if you
go along this curve and you look at
different cut points
say 486 grams 555 606 grams
um we start off very sensitive but not
very specific and as we increase we get
more specific and less sensitive that's
of course what happens
but the point of this is that we had
options of setting a cut point
based upon a chosen sensitivity and
specificity
and that was that could be chosen in
consultation with clinicians
similar results if we just looked at the
under seven year of age
group with seven millimoles per day
excretion
so we had multiple different cut points
with appropriate sensitivity
specificities that we could choose
um by using weight alone and then when
we
actually looked at some of the specimens
that we banked for these patients and
and
tested them for the presence of fat
globules microscopically
we found that adding microscopic
assessment for fat globules on top
of fecal weight in terms of predicting
positivity by the vana camera test
it improved the prediction it went from
0.70 to 0.74
for airing to the curve so that was
quite satisfying
and so um everyone was agreement that we
could replace the bandit camera test
with an assessment of weight
and assessment of fat lobules and just
put out this
big comment which says um the following
about the specimen that the weight is
and we enter the result the technology
enters the result and decides whether
it's high or normal
and it indicates the upper limit is
normal for that test and the appropriate
sensitivity and specificity
and then some further information about
black law bills and to contact myself if
there's any problems
so this also has been published this was
published in may of last year
and you can read about in the journal of
applied laboratory medicine
so the final six minutes of my talk i'll
use to
describe my final application of
laboratory data
in quality improvement so this was
actually using common laboratory results
to predict
risk of death in patients undergoing
coronary catheterization
so um you know what's interesting about
acute coronary syndrome patients is that
they can be discharged from the hospital
but then die later
days or weeks after they have their
initial catheterization
and here's some statistics the risk of
death 30 days after catherine
after initial acs episode is four
percent but by six months it's eight
percent
and if they're readmitted for um for a
cardiac cause
their their risk of death goes up
enormously
and so basically the idea is that you
want to keep patients in the hospital
initially that need it
and discharge only those patients who
are going to stay healthy or stay
healthy for as long as possible
if they come back to the hospital
there's higher more bit more morbidity
mortality and there's a greater impact
on the healthcare system
and in canada we know that up to 60 of
these unnecessary readmissions
may be preventable by being more careful
in how we assess the patients while
they're in hospital
now one solution from the lab is
actually to use existing laboratory data
to identify those who are at risk and of
course
you know the question is are we missing
gold in our backyard that gold being
simple stuff that's already in the
electronic medical record that results
in very simple laboratory tests
and so this is a big area investigation
by a number of
hospital systems in the u.s and also in
different
locations within canada as well so our
objective was to use
common lab data we're talking cbc
electrolytes to estimate
risk of death in these patients and
contrast that risk
and how well the risk is assigned to the
patients the efficiency of it
to the assessment that's used
traditionally
you know for these patients so
assessment of clinical risk factors
smoking status presence of comorbidities
body mass index family history
previous mi these sorts of things and
that'll tell us whether
that risk assessment via lab data is
useful or not so all we did
is we pulled all available laboratory
test data on patients undergoing
coronary catheterization and we linked
it
to a cardiac registry that had follow-up
data and mortality
and comorbidity that we contrast the lab
data to
and then we determine the associations
of lab test results with mortality
and created a cumulative lab risk score
that summarizes the cumulative impact of
all the different lab results on
mortality risk
and then we validated that lab risk
score in terms of its performance in a
different geographic location to be sure
that it actually works
um so this is a theoretical graph of the
um you know
uh the the course of admission and
discharge for a patient
who comes in with an acute coronary
syndrome they're admitted
they have labs they may have other labs
they have other assessments
on the left once they hit the red box
then they're having
their final set of labs and examinations
before an invasive procedure
coronary catheterization stenting
and then perhaps after the procedure
there's post-procedure labs
other investigations followed by labs
before discharge
and you know then there would be an
outcome
occurring at any point during that
process but hopefully long after they've
been discharged
the simple lab tests that we considered
in our analysis which is the cbc with
differential
electrolytes creatinine as calculated by
the
egfr total co2 and
inr and we put these data
into a logistic regression model the
data being
quintiles of each of the different lab
variables
and we essentially used a backwards
elimination technique to kick out
variables
that were not significantly associated
with mortality risk
in the linked data set after adjusting
for the impact
of the other lab lab data and so
what ended up in the final model were
things like sex
co2 sodium egfr white
white blood cell count and inr most of
these are
obviously quite important in the
assessment of patients but their
associations as indicated by the odds
ratios
some of them were unexpected for example
the higher the sodium was
the lower the risk universally for
mortality for the patient and that may
reflect
a medical response while they're while
they're an inpatient
or it may just be the provision of
fluids and and more intense
medical care to the patient um and so
what we did
with those associations in the final
model is we
created a cumulative score um a lab risk
score and you know
this logistic regression model it's
basically just a formula that adds
the individual contributions of each
predictor age sex and all the lab
variables
to create an overall risk of death for
the patient
and if you multiply those coefficients
by a constant
to make the score large and easy to work
with you can get a final number for that
patient
maybe 0.5 and if we divide those scores
into quintiles
you can graph them like this and you see
as you increase the quintile
the lab square score you increase their
risk of mortality quite substantially
unadjusted there's a 40 times higher
risk of death in these patients in the
top quintile versus the bottom
and what we found is that the c
statistic the overall performance
calcification performance of the score
in calgary in the validation population
um was very good and almost as good as
the demographic and clinical risk
factors
and this performance was was almost the
same in edmonton our valve our
external validation location
so lab data is powerful and this paper
was published
also in the journal of applied
laboratory medicine um last july
so our overall conclusions is that you
know first of all
quality improvement requires good data
which we have access to in calgary
um you have to be able to work with data
very well in order to get a conclusion
but it's really fun and extremely
rewarding so
thank you for your attention i hope you
found this talk interesting